comment il
ce sont les toilettes que ces deux
adolescents pointe du doigt c'est là
qu'ils vont au milieu des détritus
amoncelés dans l'enceinte même de leur
camp
un terrain qui appartient à edf 310
gamme vivent ici depuis le mois de juin
dans la pourriture la salubrité total
pas de toilettes pas de chauffage pas
d'eau courante pas de ramassage
d'ordures non plus ses enfants non pas
un non et c'est tout ce qu'ils
connaissent de la vie les enfants qui
l'affairé a finalement laissé congo
zaïre pour marc de pas les enfants c'est
court mieux qu'ils voyaient dans la
france une terre d'asile ont fui leur
pays la roumanie et son racisme
ils savent que dans une semaine demain
peut-être lit peuvent être expulsés mais
de toute façon ils n'ont rien à faire
berceau pour tout le camp vous faites un
fort élément ils vont manger ici et
pendant ce temps la maladie s'installe
insidieuse tuellement il ya énormément
de problèmes de galles donc on est
intervenu auprès de la das pour leur
demander s'ils pouvaient faire une
intervention à savoir qu'il faut
absolument être né d'aller dans les
caravanes
des infections parce que les soigner ce
point de vue corporelle s'associe pas la
tuberculose aussi a élu domicile dans ce
camp de mauvaises fortunes et tous les
jours gagne du terrain ce matin une
moto-école continuer imperturbable son
entraînement au milieu de ce bidonville
et de ses enfants